平等って何なの人権宣言はねほら分ものや
であるいはフェミニストかななんもすぐ
しいたげられて言ってわめくやつら権利
問題について語るな
[音楽]
よ今の教育が世界人権宣言に基づいて行わ
れてるっていうのをこれれについてお話し
いただいてもいいですか世界人権宣言読ん
だことある世界人権宣言も読まずに権利
問題についって語るなよ日本の文化系の
悪いとこな元はどうでもええ使用末節の
とこだけ見りゃええていうのが文化系の
やり方よねそこだけ覚える1番元がよう
わからんない世界人権宣言のあれ見るとね
理科系が読むとまずね最初読んだだけで
ちゃんちゃらおかしいってことになる思っ
たことないやろ権利はいいもんだ必要な
もんだ自由もそうだだけど自由とは
何かしら権利とは何かしらだけど
素晴らしいもんだその飛躍がねダメにし
ちまう何でも言えるようになっ
ちまう江戸の末期に権利と自由の思想が
流行り出して日本にあれは欧米施設断が何
回か行って向こうから持ち帰った文化を
和薬したんやねで和薬した時に最後まで
和薬できなかったのが権利ないライトそれ
を西真がハゲ犯の権利と訳したそしたら
それがよかろうということでま全ての学者
が賛同して以降ライト権利という日本語で
使うようになったでそれが流行った頃に
福沢口が文句言ってライトは権利じゃない
間違えとるぞと福吉はねあれ非常にそう
いう面では科学的な人間やからね2つの
意味で間違えとるんやとけにという訳語は
1つは剣というのは能動的な力やろ再建者
みたいにだけどライトは受動的な力でやろ
濃度的に使うんじゃないやろともう1つは
ライトの1番の元の意味は正しいやろその
正しいという意味が権利の中に入ってない
やないかその2つが違っとるからライトを
権理という言葉で使うと将来過残すよって
言っとるんやそこでからが文化系の役目な
んやぞじゃあ福沢地はどう役しとるんか
探せばええやないかこんなもの福沢生役が
いくらでもあるじゃんアメリカの独立宣言
があるじゃんアメリカの独立宣言から権利
自由というのがざっ世界中に広まったわけ
やからねそれ見てごらんライトの役として
福沢幸地は義を行う義に通る通義と訳し
とる通義と権利が同じもんだと思えるで通
の方が正しいで副基もこれで完璧には意味
は表してないけど権利なんていう
むちゃくちゃな役に比べたらよっぽど
ええって言っとるわだけどやっぱり天才は
排除されるからね副基地役は全然流行らず
に西山役が未だに流行ってるこの歴史を
ちゃんとしてね
ね恥ずかしいですね文化系としてな文化系
っていうのは非常にあの自分では作りんだ
からもう必死になって真似をするその真似
をすることアメリカや中国の文化を知って
いることが自分の優秀な証になっちゃう
さっきの権利と自由っていう部分で自由
っていう言葉についても伺ってもいいです
か権利は分かったね
はい権利はねこういうこと言っとるんよ義
というのは正しい行動のことを言うの義理
と人情を計りにかけりゃ義理が重たい男の
世間大外的な正しい行動がギリない家庭
ないみたいなね体内的な内向きの正しい
感情人情ないでその2つがぶつかる
お父さん会社が忙してうちへ帰ってこない
というタイプそういう時に家を取るか会社
を取るか男は会社を取るんだこれが義大外
的外が男の役目やからよねで義を行う通義
というのは作らんといかんやろそのまま
好きにやっとったら上に流されるからね
それを乗り越えて義を作らんといでから義
ができた時に義に通じたと言うんじゃだ
からその義を行う権利が今義を行っとんだ
からお前ら邪魔するなと結局権利というの
は今自分がやってる行動は正しいことなん
だから権力者は邪魔をするなこれが権利家
を作るのはいろんな我慢せないいかんやろ
うちに帰りたくてもそいつを押しのけて
それを繰り返すからね繰り返したら癖に
なる癖になったらそれを技術という精神的
技術これが理性だで正しい理性が
できる人権宣言はその辺が人権宣言はねほ
は分散ものやで想像論書いてあるんやから
神が人間に理性を与え自由を与え権利を
与えたということは地名の理であるって
書いてあるわこんなことが議論するまでも
ないだろキリスト教との言うことやから
あんなものはねドグマて言うんだ理論じゃ
ないあそこの中だけで通用する理論っぽい
やつそのドグマを白人どもは世界中に
押し付けとるんだからそういう信教の自由
なんて書いてある文章の中に平気で
キリスト教を入れて要すに押し付けとる
あれだけども拒否線だねだから日本は人権
宣言はAは受け入れるただ
全文は拒否するつったらいい私は神から
与えられる覚えない自分で作った理性と
いうのは自分で作るもんだ権利は自分で
作るもんない同じように自由も自分で作る
もんないだから正しいことをする権利
正しいことをする自由ない正しいがつくん
だ
全部最近その男女平等とかがよく叫ばれ
てる世の中だと思うんですけど先生の意見
を伺い
平等って何なのバカマスコミが言ってんの
はあるいはフェミニストかななんでもすぐ
女しいたげられて言ってわめく奴らやあれ
が言ってんのは同等やだから奴ら本当近頃
男も子供うめえなんて言い出したやろ
私たちも戦争に行くから男も子供うめよ
なんて平気で言うんやでそういうことが非
科学的だということがわからん
の自由だあの哲学の自由だ心情の自由だと
か言って悪いものまで自由そんな自由は
ないんやねこの使いこなせないやつが権利
と自由を言うからどかしなことになっ
ちゃうんよ
[音楽]
ねDET